and we have each other because as long
as we have that
i mean what else do we need danielle
busby is setting the record
straight after fans speculate she's had
a tummy tuck since welcoming her now
five-year-old quintuplets remember once
the color's gone it's gone
okay and there's a bunch of y'all so you
just sprinkle a little bit
the out dotted star got candid with her
fans during a recent instagram q a
when one person asked her if she had had
plastic surgery
after giving birth a question danielle
said
she gets a lot quote no i have not had a
tummy tuck but i would not think any
less of someone else wanting to get one
oh and she wasn't done i know the after
body challenges are body faces after
going through pregnancy so if some other
mom
chose to have a tummy tuck by all means
you do
you the reality star and her hubby adam
busby welcomed daughters hazel
riley parker ava and olivia in 2015.
they are also parents to a nine-year-old
daughter blake
it's never easy being a parent but
here we are with six kids and trying to
do our best and
sometimes you get faced with these big
decisions and the mom of six has
previously opened up about her workout
routine
and how important it is to make time for
yourself back in september she shared
this shot writing in part quote just
remember
every day there is one thing you mamas
need to remember
and that is you we gotta get used to
life with six kids and it's gonna be
hard
and sometimes getting that fitness in
means including the kiddos
she shared this pic with two of her
daughters alongside the caption quote
these two birds love yoga and did the
whole session with me
they did so great meanwhile danielle has
been battling a mystery illness for
months now she and her husband have both
taken to social media to share
updates on her health as well as ask for
prayers
earlier this month the 37 year old
reality star opened up about her health
journey on her insta story
explaining that she had seen a
cardiologist and a rheumatologist
lots of tests have been done for both
doctors some results have come back
okay and some not so much
and a few days later she shared this
photo explaining that after having some
tests done
she learned she wouldn't need surgery
while danielle says there's still no
clear answer about what's going on
she's extremely grateful for all the
well wishes from her fans
you